dans la session régionale de la chambre
d'agriculture il est d'abord question du
nouveau découpage de la carte des zones
défavorisées simples mais les acteurs du
monde agricole sont également concernés
par la déclaration faite ce jeudi par le
président macron le chef de l'état a
annoncé sa volonté de mettre en place
des verrous réglementaire sur les achats
de terres agricoles par des étrangers en
france
une bonne nouvelle pour le président de
la chambre d'agriculture de la dhr dont
de nombreuses terres et fermes ont été
achetés par de gros investisseurs
chinois
il faut le reconnaître on sent une
volonté de législateur est transmise par
le président de la république 1
de vouloir faire en sorte que ce
phénomène ne se développe pas
aujourd'hui se développe pas mais
peut-être aussi parce que il ya eu tout
de suite une mobilisation du législateur
pour bien contrôler éviter que ça se
généralise et ça a été réaffirmée par le
président wade
je crois que c'est une bonne chose un
peu plus méfiant cet agriculteur de
l'indre attend les effets de la mesure
pour lui les investisseurs chinois sont
vraiment très entreprenant on a de
belles paroles mais il n'y a rien comme
entièrement qui nous permet de réguler
ce fonds c'est d'empêcher ces
investisseurs c'est à dire que les
chinois investissent dans l'indre c'est
pas le problème le problème c'est qu'il
fait on savoir direct l'objectif c'était
25 mille hectares sur département de
l'indre on a tellement mis le bordel que
les chinois n'aiment pas du tout parce
qu'ils n'aiment pas qu'on passe dans les
médias et tout ça ils ont fait marche
arrière ils sont rabattus sur l'allier
maintenant aussi l'allier ne fait pas
attention ça arrivera la même chose donc
il faut être prudent
1700 hectares dans l'indre 9000 dans
l'allier le milliardaire chinois
acheteurs de ces terres vient d'ouvrir
une première boulangerie dans un
complexe chic de pékin afin de bonifier
la farine issue des plaines du centre
france